por medio de las redes sociales que la
iglesia católica denunció este
allanamiento en contra de la diócesis de
matagalpa la policia orteguista habría
entrado a las tres de la mañana
justamente para capturar para detener a
monseñor rolando álvarez de 55 años uno
de los más fuertes críticos del régimen
de ortega junto con otros sacerdotes y
otros laicos y hasta el momento se
desconoce el paradero de donde puedan
estar estos religiosos monseñor rolando
álvarez usted bien lo decía llevaba 16
días de asedio en esta diócesis y es uno
de los más fuertes críticos porque desde
que comenzaron las protestas
antigobierno en 2018 él ha sido quien ha
pedido la liberación de los más de 180
considerados presos políticos y ha
condenado a más la muerte de las 355
personas que cuenta la comisión
interamericana de derechos humanos que
pues se realizaron en el marco de estas
protestas antigobierno
nicaragua es un país de 65 millones de
habitantes en donde el 58 por ciento es
religioso y la influencia de este
monseñor es muy importante junto con
ella serían cuatro los sacerdotes
arrestados este año 10 en custodia por
el régimen de ortega y las reacciones
internacionales pues ya han comenzado a
sonar luís almagro de la organización de
estados americanos condenó esta
detención a sí mismo como el
representante del vaticano en la oea le
pidió a la santa sede- que se pronuncie
que no permanezca en silencio y esta es
una de las más fuertes críticas que se
le dice que el papá francisco se
mantiene en silencio y no ha dicho nada
contra esta denominada persecución
religiosa nicaragua ahora andrés a que
se ven estas tensiones entre la iglesia
y el gobierno ortega y porque ortega en
que aumentaba esta serie contra los
religiosos
bueno no son nuevas estas tensiones son
perduran por más de 35 años las
tensiones entre la iglesia católica y
los gobiernos los diferentes gobiernos
pero sobre todo con ortega se han
pronunciado este año por ejemplo hemos
podido ver que se prohibió a la
arquidiócesis de managua realizar el
tradicional desfile la tradicional
procesión de la virgen de fátima o por
ejemplo en marzo de 2022 retiraron al
nuncio apostólico del vaticano valdemar
estanislao que viene siendo como el
embajador del vaticano fue expulsado
también fueron expulsadas las hermanas
de la madre madre teresa de calcuta 18
religiosas que tuvieron que cruzar hasta
costa rica el cierre de ocho emisoras
ahora la detención de estos sacerdotes y
sobre todo porque usted muy bien lo
decía
es ortega quien cree que los religiosos
están organizando grupos violentos
incitándolos a ejecutar actos de odio y
mantienen a la población en sus obras
en contra del estado nicaragüense